hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we're going to be chatting about
WWDC it just happened this past week and
I'm sure many of you are like just
seeing yeah we know we watch the
announcement and everyone else is
already posted videos the full recap
full product details and everything that
you probably needed to know when you
needed to know it but I'm late and I've
got a very good reason you guys didn't
watch my WWDC predictions video and you
probably weren't aware of what I was
doing so for those that missed it I'm a
huge tool fan yes
tools like they are my absolute favorite
band they have been one of my biggest
inspirations since 1999 when I first
found them I was all in Pittsburgh for
one of their shows and I got a chance to
do their VIP experience where I got you
like sitting on their soundcheck and
Adam did a two-hour Q&A with everybody
that was there and it was absolutely the
best time of my life they also took our
phones away so I had no communication
with anyone I didn't know what was
happening during WWDC but it was all
worth it in the end we got to hear a new
song like we heard he had played us a
new song and you as a tool fans man you
know how special of an experience that
is and if you're not then I don't even
know what to say because you probably
can't even listen to them anywhere
because they're not Spotify but not on
iTunes you can't even find the music
anywhere if you would find full albums
here on YouTube which is how I usually
listen to them anyway this is a video
about WTC at Apple so let's get into why
you guys are here and I can rant about
to later I'm sorry I don't like I don't
have any friends and sitter tool fans so
when I find people that are fans I just
want to talk to them and discuss so if
any of you guys are fans let me know in
the comments below so some of the big
highlights for me that I had read about
was obviously the home pod of which I
was hoping it would be called the series
speaker because that just sounds so
freaking cute it's a home pod now so
that's I think one of the main selling
points of this thing is it use a special
awareness to tune and better fill the
room with sound based on the space that
it's in so this is the thing that will
be interesting for me because I have my
entire house decked out in so no speaker
and everything that I do basically is
integrated into Sonos so will this Siri
speaker replace my Soto sound system so
some time the differentiates this from
Sonos is you can actually talk to it and
ask it questions like who's the drummer
of this song
what album came out 20 years ago today
so with that kind of integration and
actually having a conversation
essentially with your speaker is kind of
neat the home pod is priced at 349 and
is supposed to be shipping in December
which is pretty soon so it'll be out
just in time for the holidays in the
case of Apple film pod you only have one
choice Apple music and I've been a huge
Spotify fan since the very beginning I
had a Spotify account before was even
available in the u.s. I'm going to
remember how I got it but I had access
to a pre-release version of it it wasn't
even available yet in the US so I've
been such a huge Spotify fan for so long
so that's it the series is still called
a bit serious speaker that the home pod
will not work with Spotify or anything
else except Apple music is hmm it kind
of hurts hurts right here and of course
they make sense because it is Apple and
this is definitely classic Apple
behavior I'm not sure why I thought that
this would be any different either way
they saw my Christmas wish list here it
is my sister tweeted something really
funny and she tweeted like this ball of
yarn and it actually looked exactly like
the home pod the new sound of home break
through speaker so there's our little
internal so that's the home pod the next
thing that they also analysis WGC is an
iMac pro an iMac pro what Oh calls are
horses look at this thing it is a
beautiful space grey I mean it looks
absolutely incredible and here is where
I'm having my dilemma because everybody
has been holding out and fingers crossed
since the original Mac Pro came out in
2013 we've been waiting for a Mac Pro
but no you don't give us a Mac Pro you
gave us an iMac Pro which is it's so
tempting like I don't know what to do I
loved my iMac my sister has the 5k iMac
which I held out and did not get and
instead I waited for the latest MacBook
Pro that I currently have which is the
one with the touch bar and I've been
using that as my main machine that's
what I use every single day I edit all
of my videos on it I usually edit from
an external drive so I don't actually
have any files on it that I add it from
before I would have my Mac Pro at home
or my iMac whatever it was that I was
editing on
I would everything on the external drive
and when I would travel I would take my
macbook with me and everything
editing would be right on the drive so I
wouldn't have to worry about do I have
this file do I not have this file it
would always be on the external where
are the specs 8 10 or 18 core browser
like that so absolutely nuts the anti
Pro can accommodate up to 128 gigs oh
one of things that I love doing is
setting out any computer that I have to
the max amount of RAM that it can
accommodate and this one can go up to
128 gigs which is pretty freakin
impressive has up to a 4 terabyte solid
state drive and editing off of a
solid-state drive if you haven't done so
before especially if you're doing 4k
footage it has completely changed
everything I'm actually able to edit
almost double as fast as I was able to
before so beautiful a three USB C port
with do I get this or do I hold out for
the Mac pearl which I think is what I'm
going to do I mean you now can get a
space great keyboard and a mouse and a
trackpad a court and an SD card slot
you're so thoughtful three USB three
Thunderbolt 3 and even though my gosh
everything about this is so beautiful
I'm just sitting here like I'm in love
with it anyway let's move on to iOS 11
which was another huge announcement and
I absolutely love when they have is
updates because it basically makes you
feel like you have sort of an entirely
fresh new phone sometimes unless you
have an old phone and you update and
then it completely crashes and it makes
your phone slower which does sometimes
happen so of my favorite things that
I've seen so far in iOS 11 is actually
for the iPad now absent stresses so much
and they keep talking about having the
iPad replace your computer and that's
not quite feasible especially for me
most pro users are not going to be able
to take everything that they are
currently doing on their desktop or on
their laptop and do the same exact
things they need to do on their iPad but
with this latest update we're getting a
little bit closer to actually having
that be a possibility for more people
they have a new customizable dock on the
iPad so it'll allow you to have access
to frequently used apps it's easy to
switch between multitasking
functionality like a split view and
slide over there's also a new app
switcher so any of your apps they're
already opened so it's kind of likely
sat on your desktop you can go through
and push up I actually haven't done this
in such a long time and it's actually
not all that's in Windows it's command
holy-moly I'm losing my mom but you know
what I meant this is also pretty cool a
files app it's also available on the
iPad so it lets you access all of your
files regardless if they're stored
locally or in the cloud or other
services like Dropbox or Google Drive
this is also extremely exciting
system-wide drag-and-drop thank you so
it makes it super easy to drag and drop
images text links and basically anything
that you need for one app to another
like if you've got some photos in your
camera who you can track and drop those
into an email finally there's a new
instant note feature so you can open
notes from the lockscreen just by
tapping Apple pencil on the display I
love other finally integrating Apple
pencil more even though it's a little
bit late I feel like it's been out for
so long there's just so much potential
for it and it sort of has just been kind
of left behind unless you're an
illustrator is perfect for you Siri will
be able to translate English words into
Chinese French German Italian and
Spanish I'm also a big fan of this it's
but do not disturb mode while driving
what enables while driving do not
disturb result incoming notifications
and let people know that you're driving
and will go back to them later 20 huge
fan of augmented reality which is why
I'm so excited that apple also announced
their a are tipped SDK those are the
part of developers that will allow
people to build high quality a our
experiences and games into the iPhone
and iPad I absolutely love VR I think
it's incredible because it really does
take you out of where you are into
another world but I love augmented
reality because you're still in a place
that's familiar but it takes those
surroundings and then turn them into
something else I think there's so much
incredible potential where they are so
I'm so excited to see Apple sort of
furthering and pushing that envelope of
what AR can do there's also a new iPad
pro it is a ten and a half inch model
look at it man it's beautiful so new
iPad pro retina sports and 120 Hertz wow
that's actually kind of crazy so movies
and video looks spectacular while game
is placed smoothly without distractions
so that's pretty exciting for anyone who
has held out and isn't looking to get an
iPad this could potentially be the one
for you so I don't think
the iPad I think in the iPad Department
I am just completely SPECT out maybe
I'll try to get one to review for you
guys but for the most part I feel like
for me most of our work is done on my
laptop and on my iPhone and I feel like
with those two things I am completely
set I don't need anything else maybe I
need that I met Pro but I think that
might be more of a once men ameed
it looks so good I wish so badly that
Apple would have released instead of the
iMac Pro they would have released an
iMac monitor like that same monitor just
not an iMac so I could just use my
laptop plug it in I wouldn't so good
anyways looking more at the iPad and the
new iOS 11 update I mean this looks so
cool just multitasking I mean this is
going to move people so much closer to
actually being able to use the iPad as a
full-fledged computer I love the Apple
pencil I just wish I had more of a use
for it ok did you just draw that because
that looks really good they also
announced the new name of the next
operating system and it's called high
sierra sound strange so if your Mac
elevated essentially taking the previous
OS and making it a little bit better but
I guess not making enough changes to
signify an entirely new name not sure
get a boost with new technologies boy do
I love new technologies Apple file
system home response it's safe and
secure I love safety and I love security
this is something that I can hunter
percent get behind a PVC is the new
standard for video and I've been
struggling a lot with video storage file
sizes are unbelievably massive you guys
can't actually maybe you can I'll just
move this book do you see all this
hard drives I am currently going through
a data crisis and the crisis is what do
I do with all of this stuff I'm
currently looking into storage options
and I think I found one so when I do
find out what I'm going to do with all
this stuff I'll let you guys know a PV C
is going to be the new video standard it
stands for high efficiency video coding
and breath up to 40% more than h.264
stream better and take up less space on
your Mac that is something that I need
to hear Michael sigh Ciara let's develop
this great interactive virtual reality
experiences on the Macs for the first
time also super excited about that
favorite apps and features get a boost
more ways to edit and organize your
photos expanded sidebar alrighty this is
also something that I think is
interesting there's a Fitness focus
update which includes monthly challenges
which is also kind of nice so you can
tap your Apple watch on certain gym
equipment that uses that NFC technology
so you're able to get more accurate data
from your workout so if you just ran
three and a half miles your Apple watch
might not be 100% accurate as the
treadmill that you were just running on
because it has the data and it knows
exactly what you just did tap and go
this I forgot to mention Apple pay
person-to-person payments in iMessage so
there's so many times where my sister
will buy something and then I have to
pay her back and it's a whole struggle
I'll either use venmo or PayPal or bank
specific payments that you
person-to-person payments this is going
to be so easy like if I owe her money I
can just iMessage for money it's about
time I feel like it's a very standard
thing that's been a long time coming and
here it is okay well I guess that's the
thing thank you guys so much for
watching let me know what your
highlights were of WDC what are you
looking forward to in the future there
were no announcements as per usual about
any of the latest iPhones that will be
coming out no iPhone 7s new iPhone 8 I
always have these hopes and I just think
that they're going to say something just
as a little surprised but wEDC isn't the
place for that and I know that we all
know it but yet we still have hopes III
is also coming up this week so stay
tuned for lots of updates I'm so
freaking excited to hear more about xbox
Scorpio I cannot wait I have a bunch of
e3 videos coming up so stay tuned for
those and I will see you guys
so you get later and I talked a lot in
this video I'm so sorry
did it make any sense I don't know
[Music]